I never thought I'd see the day where
Jesse pinkman's in space yes science
black mirror's third episode this season
is a tragic tale of Love loss and a
third Culkin brother but in this video
we're gonna take a deep dive Beyond the
Sea no not that one and explore its
ending secrets and Black Mirror Easter
eggs and be sure to like And subscribe
I'll be covering every episode this
season this is David Ross or should I
say a replica slash machine version of
him his real life body is millions of
miles away on an unknown Mission across
space but scientists have devised a
device that can transfer the
consciousness of its real-life host to a
replica version back on Earth this
allows David to live his life on Earth
while also completing his mission in
space joining him is fellow astronaut
Cliff Stanfield he too has a replica
which allows him to see his family
however as the first few moments of the
story unfold it's clear that David and
Cliff are two very different people
David is the loving husband and father
well Cliff is distant in Stern David
lets his daughter act up and complain
while Cliff is quick to hit his son
Henry should he fall out of line but
their differences don't stop there David
lives in the city takes his family out
to the movies and is happy to chat with
fans about his mission well Cliff
purposely moves his family away from the
city to the seclusion of the country in
fact the first book we see Cliff's wife
Lana reading is Arthur Haley's airport a
story about a man's Devotion to his job
tearing apart his family and his
marriage our first Easter egg comes at
the movie theater where you can see a
list of films playing one in particular
space Fleet is a nod to season 4's USS
Callister not much is known about this
Mission throughout the episode we only
get a few bits of information for
example they are on year two with four
more years to go which is a hell of a
lot of time considering how this story
ends in terms of what this mission is we
only get one line The Human Experience
the survival human body of life that's
really Central to the mission perhaps
their mission revolves around life's
ability to survive in space they also
have a room filled with different plants
but I'm unsure whether that's just for
oxygen or research purposes the episode
is titled Beyond the Sea which is the
English language version of La Mer the
song that plays while David Gets a bit
frisky with his wife it is also the song
that plays at the end of the episode its
lyric tells of lovers reuniting from
Beyond the Sea although in this context
it's space as we get closer to the
stories inciting incident the
differences between cliff and David
become ever more apparent David can't
keep his hands off his wife well Cliff
won't even kiss her goodbye David's room
in space is filled with pictures of his
family of Life signified by a bonsai
tree well Cliffs is Barren now David's
World Turns Upside Down with the arrival
of a hippie gang led by Rory culkins
Kappa this is actually hinted at a few
scenes earlier when David life notices
an odd van parked across the street from
their house each of these hippies are
named after letters of the Greek
alphabet and they've become obsessed
with David believing he's an Abomination
that David goes against everything that
is natural you may have also noticed
Kappa reciting this line No Stranger the
crowd could doubt it says Casey at the
bath this is a line from Ernest Lawrence
Thayer's poem Casey At The Bat which
tells of a star player failing to live
up to the expectations of his fans and
as we'll see with David this is
definitely true I couldn't help but
think cap and his crew are a take on
Charles Manson and his followers both
incidents took place in 1969 by deranged
hippies who smeared the blood of their
victims on the wall in fact when Cliff
sees a photograph of the blood in the
paper it makes out the white bear symbol
from season two something I found
interesting is when David is knocked
unconscious it only takes him a few
seconds to insert his tag back into the
machine and get back to Earth however
when he's transported back back to his
replica several minutes have passed he's
constrained and his family has been
rounded up suggesting there's a several
minute delay when a signal from the ship
to the replica occurs unfortunately
Kappa and his crew end up killing
David's family and destroying David's
replica leaving him to live out the next
four years alone up in space Cliff tells
his wife they can't make another replica
but even if they did what does that
loved here David is a Broken Man and I'd
feel like too if this is all I had
to eat for the next four years Cliff
ends up worried for David's mental
health and also his own life for if
David did anything to jeopardize the
mission it would be Cliff's life on the
line too as he says the mission can only
be done with the two of them alive so
Cliff suggests a drastic plan to cheer
David up let him use his replica Lana is
okay with this idea of another man
inhabiting the body of her husband she's
now reading Valley of the Dolls a 1966
novel by Jacqueline Suzanne which tells
of the personal and professional
struggles of three young women as they
try to make it in the entertainment
industry in New York Lana will later
call the book trashy but it's a fantasy
to help her escape from the loneliness
she herself faces it's ironic then that
her husband is millions of miles away
yet she's the one who's lonely David's
use of Cliff's replica increases as for
one hour a week he's allowed to use it
to help paint a portrait for Cliff's
house but what ensues is a budding
relationship between David and Lana both
of them are incredibly alone and David
uses every opportunity he can to spend
more time with her is there a hardware
store in town they end up at a Bookshop
called Cooper's books which may or not
be named after Cooper from season
three's play test there David suggests
Lana reads the Moon is a Harsh Mistress
which is all about the residents of the
Moon revolting against Earth's Authority
it could be a subtle hint at Lana
revolting against Cliff but things take
a turn journal and David gets a little
too close to Lana putting the moves on
her the same way he did to his wife even
though deep down Lana wants this
connection she's still true to her
husband warding off David's advances and
making for one hell of an awkward
situation Lana doesn't tell Cliff about
what happened and only when Cliff's
treadmill breaks down does he and his
boredom search David's room and uncovers
nude drawings of his wife or so Cliff
gives David a big old Shiner to the face
but David's quick to let him know how he
really feels you I've got it all
and you don't even care Cliff has it all
but doesn't care and David has nothing
but cares back on Earth cliff and
Cliff's replica confronts his wife about
the affair and Lana is brutally honest
so no he didn't touch me but I wished he
did I it's here Cliff realizes what a
terrible husband he's been neglecting
his wife and not being the man he should
be he apologizes to her accepts his
faults and it seems like he and Lana are
ready to move on but there's still the
question of David who has four more
years up in space when Cliff returns to
the ship David wants one last
opportunity to use Cliff's replica and
apologize to Lana or at least say
goodbye Cliff doesn't allow this stating
that Lana never wants to speak to him
again the thought of you returning makes
her vomit we never find out if Lana
actually said these things or if it was
just Cliff digging into him but it's
certain that these words inspired David
to do what he does next Cliff is called
back to the ship for an emergency
coolant leak as we saw earlier in the
video Cliff seems to be the one in
charge of any repairs outside the ship
but when Cliff gets out there he
realizes nothing is broken David has
used this opportunity to go into Cliff's
replicant and Kill la Anna now you might
be asking yourself did he do this to get
back at Lana or at Cliff now I
personally leaned more toward Cliff
evidenced by when he kicks the chair
over almost as if to say come join me in
my hell he wanted to see the pain on
Cliff's face there's no mention on what
happened to Cliff's son and whether or
not he was murdered too however I love
this spinning shot when Cliff discovers
the body which not only depicts his
world turning upside down but mimics the
spinning of the earth you may have also
noticed that David reads a book by Ray
Bradbury called The Illustrated Man it's
a collection of short stories which deal
with the recurring theme of the cold
mechanics of technology and the human
psyche how has technology affected the
psychology of our characters here now
the implications of David's decision are
quite profound will the authorities on
Earth blame Cliff for the murders and
what will Cliff do now that his family
is dead if he kills David he'd be
killing himself as he previously said
this ship needs two people to to survive
the episode ends with the titular song
Beyond the Sea playing as our characters
drift further and further away from
Earth those they love and perhaps their
own sanity thanks for watching everyone
please be sure to like And subscribe and
let me know in the comments below what
you thought about Beyond the Sea where
more about takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember yes science